[Applaus]
sie essen allein mit christian beer
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der name christian konnten sie und ihr
team im sondierungs papier schon
regelrechte inhalte feststellen nein
leider nein prüfaufträge ja
binsenweisheiten klar gute vorsätze fürs
neue jahr jede menge aber inhalte nein
tatsächlich haben wir herausgefunden
dieses papier ist so leicht inhaltlich
ja es stimmt sogar in milch habe ich
zeige ihnen das gros der wahnsinn
und mein lieblingssatz in diesem papier
ist dieser hier
wir wollen eine stabile und
handlungsfähige regierung bilden
und jetzt kommt das richtige tut sein
doch regierung die das richtige tun
diese verrückten 130 noch nie versucht
vor der heutigen neuland ja was wir aber
leider nicht mal unter dem
elektronenmikroskop entdecken konnten
das ist irgendeine cdu handschrift die
spd kriegs kitas für umme csu kriegt
irgendwas gegen flüchtlinge aber die cdu
fehlanzeige bullinger gar nichts wenn
ich mein studium frau merkel die muss
ich doch als kanzlerin irgendwas
vorgenommen haben für die nächsten vier
jahre
ich bin jetzt optimistisch dass die
dinge voran gehen dass wir noch schwere
dinge und dann spüren wir eine aufgabe
für seine aufgabe
ein tipp von mir oliver wenn sie hier
eine aufgabe spüren ja wenn das hier so
zieht ganz schnell zu machen stehen also
also doch recht hohe phrasen dichte
würden sie sagen das würde ich wohl
sagen ja hier zb wir wollen familien in
ihrem anliegen unterstützen mehr zeit
füreinander zu haben und die
partnerschaft zu stärken
ich will aber gar nicht mehr zeit mit
meiner familie die groko will dass ich
mal ein bisschen zusammen
leider gibt es aber auch ein paar echt
ärgerliche stellen stichwort rente die
feiern sich war das rentenniveau bis
2025 nicht unter 48 prozent fallen soll
tatsächlich wird das bis dahin sowieso
nicht unter 48 fallen danach wird's
bitter wenn die baby boomer in rente
gehen dann droht massenhaft altersarmut
und dann sagte merkel
manchmal muss man sagen okay passiert
bekommt 2025 das ist in sieben jahren
quasi science fiction ob sie dann noch
leben weiß gar nicht
ja gut immerhin der ehering gibt es
jetzt steht im papier eine grundrente
stand 2013 auch schon drin hieß solidar
rente hat leider nicht geklappt schade
aber hier rückkehr recht auf teilzeit in
vollzeit stand 2013 auch schon drin hat
leider nicht geklappt
ein nationaler bildungsrat soll das
thema bildung zwischen bund und ländern
koordinieren
gut dass ich es ansprechen das gibt's
seit 1948 heißt kultusministerkonferenz
mit anderen worten raider heißt jetzt
twix sonst ändert sich nichts
christa
die fans nicht gut sie ziehen die leute
ja total runter jetzt sagen sie
gefälligst noch mal was positives
ok ich schaue noch mal rein also ja
vielleicht kann man sagen dass europa
kapitel ist ganz ordentlich
mehrere seiten europa wo im grunde steht
europa ist eine feine sache oder oder
oder anders ausgedrückt es lebe die
deutsch französische freundschaft wie
viele mit franco allemand
[Applaus]
bei der sendung mit der maus würden sie
jetzt sagen das war weder deutsch noch
französisch mit christine
[Applaus]